hello everyone
welcome to the active inference lab and
to the model stream
2.0 today is going to be a really
awesome discussion so let's just
introduce ourselves and get right into
it i'm daniel friedman i'm a
postdoctoral researcher
in davis california ryan
um yep so i'm ryan smith i'm an
associate investigator at
the uh laureate institute for brain
research
hi i'm christopher i'm a phd student at
the university of cambridge
and i'm max murphy and i'll be starting
my post-doctoral fellowship at carnegie
mellon
in hopefully a week awesome thanks to
ryan and christopher the authors uh or
two of the three authors of this paper
for joining today and for max for
lending your expertise as well
so this is the second model stream in a
multi-part series
that is going to be highlighting
perspectives and addressing questions
related to applied active inference and
so right now we're looking at the
tutorial paper of
smith at all a step-by-step tutorial on
active inference
and its application to empirical data
the link
uh you can find in the video description
so if you have any questions or
thoughts or comments during the live
stream type it in the youtube live chat
and we'll be monitoring that
and then if you have any questions after
the live stream leave a comment on the
video or get in touch with us another
way
and we'll try to address it in a future
session and if you want to learn more or
if you want to participate
go to activeinference.org all right
so today in our second session we're
going to be picking up
with a brief overview and summary of
where we're at where we've been
we're going to go through a few
clarifying questions that have been
raised in the last week and then we're
going to dive into the specific examples
and
into the code and do some code walk
through so that will be really exciting
all right so i'll just throw out the
first opening question which is
who is this session for what kinds of
tools
and skills would you say are required
and which kinds of tools or skills might
be
helpful
um okay well um
i mean i would say that the session and
i mean really the entire tutorial is for
people who
um are just kind of i mean mainly people
who are just starting out people who
want to be able who are interested in
active inference
um but maybe don't have a lot of
background in mathematics you know
especially like people coming from like
neuroscience and psychology backgrounds
for example that
want to or people who do some
computational modeling
but like maybe like simpler
reinforcement learning models things
like that
where active inference is kind of
notoriously a little bit more
kind of like black box you know it's
harder to kind of break into
um a lot of people think that the models
are described in a way that's kind of
like opaque
um you know and so the the idea was to
give people
the background needed um and the actual
example
code um that would be needed that could
be adapted to
build your own models do your own
simulation studies and apply
and build models of task studies and be
able to fit models to data
in other words to kind of start to
finish to be able for a person who wants
to to be able to
use active inference models to model
data in empirical studies and actually
use them in their own research
so as far as tools necessary um you know
the main thing
right now is going to be having some
minimal understanding or
motivation to learn how to use matlab
you know so you know we in the um
tutorial code so i mean we have
like seven or eight different you know
tutorial scripts you know this point but
the main one
is um the one that i'll be focusing on
today and it's very heavily commented
um so it kind of best we did try to
describe kind of like line by line each
thing that's going on i mean it's
honestly
there's enough comments and there'd
almost be kind of like a second paper in
and of itself
um so um you know we're hoping
um that even someone who doesn't have a
ton of background in matlab will be able
to kind of
bootstrap their way up um but
you definitely need to have a little bit
or be motivated to learn at least a
little bit
anything else to add on that christopher
or max
no i think that sums it up well just one
note on the code there so you mentioned
it's in matlab now what about other
programming languages or backgrounds
like
python so what other languages are
people in the active inference space
developing in
and how could we include more computer
languages as well as
natural human languages so i mean
there are so at present everything is
almost exclusively in matlab
unfortunately
and the reason for that is is that a lot
of this is actually built off of
spm scripts you know that carl fristen
originally wrote
in relation to uh neural imaging
approaches so things like
dynamic puzzle modeling and so
a lot of a lot of the current scripts
for doing active inference
call on a broad range of other spm
scripts that are used for a lot of
different purposes
for instance in sort of
dealing with large matrices in like
neuroimaging
so that so for that reason
and because carl is primarily worked in
matlab and relation spm
everything has kind of been in spm and
specifically in what's called the
dem toolbox in spm12
stands for dynamic expectation
maximization
there's a ton of active inference
scripts as well as a ton of other
modeling scripts for say like continuous
models and other sorts of things
in there and we just make use of
a couple of those um the main ones not
the ones they call on but
um but uh that being said
there are people who are trying at the
moment
to um translate some of the stuff into
python
uh alec schatz for example um
is currently in the process of trying to
put together uh
python versions of some of the main
simulation and inversion scripts um
i don't i mean they're very kind of in
beta at the moment as i understand them
but i know i know that that's something
that's in progress
cool so it sounds like because this
project has such a history
of being developed in matlab and the spm
toolkit and carl fristan's
research and collaborations were um
drawing heavily on matlab
however in the modern development
context
there's a lot of open source projects
that are developing in python
so that's definitely an area we'll hope
to be expanding and also a great
opportunity
for people who are experienced in python
or matlab and want to be curious about
active inference
this is the opening to help contribute
to something that could be really
exciting
so just a last um last uh
warm-up introduction question what kinds
of projects
or questions or investigations do you
think
this could apply to for somebody who
they've heard of scientific modeling but
not active inference modeling
what do you think are some low-hanging
fruit or really straightforward
interpretations where you think it could
be applied
so i mean i guess there's a couple
questions here i mean one is
um you know like well i guess the main
one is
given that the kind of history of
computational modeling has um
largely um than in the um like
reinforcement learning
i mean a sort of literature or i mean
there are others like drift of fusion
modeling and things like that but
um um the you know one of the kind of
major questions is oh well active
inference models seem
like they're really complicated you know
relative to some of these
simpler uh sort of traditional
reinforcement learning models
um so what is it that active inference
actually adds right
like what can you do using an active
inference model in a study
that um you maybe couldn't do or
could do as naturally using standard
sorts of existing reinforcement learning
models
and you know here the the kind of answer
that i would want to give is there's a
few parts to this
one is that um because
the kind of value or cost function in
active inference is expected for energy
as opposed to a reward function
and because the expected free energy has
a reward a reward component and an
information
value component then it's it's quite a
bit more natural
in active inference models to
model explore exploit tasks you know so
tasks where
the agent has to somehow intrinsically
assign value to seeking information
as a means of knowing how to maximize
reward eventually
so there are and there are actually two
different types
of um sort of directed or goal driven
explanation
or exploration in active inference one
is um
which is called parameter exploration
and the idea here is this is probably
the closest thing to um reinforcement
learning where say the agent might not
start out knowing what the reward
probabilities are
if they choose one action versus another
so they will choose actions
that will help them essentially learn
best what the reward probabilities are
before you know just reliably you're
continuously selecting the same option
right because that's the kind of know
which one's the most rewarding
first so that's called parameter
exploration
and that that like i said has analogs
in reinforcement learning but doesn't
have like a
specific in in standard models anyway it
doesn't have a very specific
sort of information drive um
to uh to seek that out um but there are
some so things like information bonus
terms uh
there's different things like that in
reinforcement learning that can do
something like that
um but they're kind of tacked on their
little little they have a little more
kind of like ad hoc feeling to them i
guess um
whereas it kind of emerges naturally
from expected free energy in active
inference
um there's also something that's a
little more unique in active inference
which is called state exploration
and that's more where you're just kind
of choosing to move to states
that you expect will give you the most
precise observations
about what state you're in um you know
so this would be the thing like
you don't know whether you're in the
green room or the red room so you should
go turn on a light
so you'll know which which room you're
in um
right so that also falls out of expected
free energy very naturally
but not out of a lot of other
traditional computational modeling
approaches um
the uh there's also sorry i could go out
for a while about this but
there's also something in reinforcement
learning models that has to do with
explore exploit called random
exploration
where people essentially start behaving
more randomly
if they're uncertain if they know they
have to make a bunch more future choices
but those values are typically fixed in
reinforcement learning models
whereas the uh expected free energy
precision
uh parameter and active inference is
actually a dynamically updated
version of that so it changes to remain
driving essentially the amount of
randomness and behavior that's
um expected given past observations
um and so that's kind of nice um
the last thing i would say is is that
active inference has a very kind of
specific neural process theory
associated with it
so it makes very specific predictions
about the neural responses you ought to
see
in studies whereas most other models
don't
so those are that's what i would say
thanks for the answer
any thoughts on that or any of the
questions christopher or max
i would just say very broadly speaking
active inference is really great for
modeling decision-making under
uncertainty
and in particular perceptual
various types of perceptual decision
making and
indiscreet state spaces so you can do
anything from modeling
so like ryan and i have some previous
work where we show
that you can reproduce a whole lot of
kind of classic
visual awareness neural correlates and
like the classic visual awareness
paradigms
for example using a hierarchical model
and the reason we can do that is because
it had
active inference has such a detailed and
rich process theory attached to it
and so for me i think what's really
unique about it is that
so there's lots of different ways of
providing unified explanations but one
way that you might want to provide a
unifying explanation is just have a
unifying set
of kind of uh com unifying computation
or one computational architecture where
you can draw in all of these different
things
into one paradigm and then understand or
well one computational paradigm that is
then understand how they're related
through the different parameters that
are being modulated when you
or being fit when you build models for
example
so i'm not aware of any other modeling
paradigm really where you could model
things as diverse
as a basic kind of explore exploit task
or looking at kind of phasic dopamine
dynamics
and then something that goes all the way
up to something like visual awareness
or even like planning and bellman
optimal planning
so to me that's what's so special about
this if you
if you want to unify things under one
umbrella this is really
um yeah one one last thing i'll say and
this is just kind of a practical
nice thing is this is that the in most
other um
modeling approaches you actually have to
kind of change the equations
you know like to fit it to a specific um
you know task
whereas an active inference technically
you don't all you do
is the the actual update equations are
always identical
all you have to do is write down the
appropriate generative model
um so it's nice because it's really
generic and
and you know once you have the
generative model specified everything
else kind of just comes for free
and just to jump in off of that uh
generalizability the the
reason i'm interested i'm somebody who
studies movement a totally
different area of neuroscience than
decision making
and uncertainty modeling but at the same
time
this framework what kind of interests me
about it is that
exactly that which is that it seems that
i can start out with kind of a structure
generative model that is consistent even
across domains
and then potentially use that to to
apply it to my own neuroscientific
research
um the the main questions that i have
and things that i'll be interested to
hear about moving forward would be
um you know we talked about that we can
use it both for parameter exploration
and state exploration but when we're in
in the empirical context of the
experiments being performed for
um it might be the case that i'm
uncertain about certain parameters
or i'm uncertain about the state and i
may be uncertain about both of those
things simultaneously
so um finding a way to either design my
experiments so that i impose certainty
on either the state or the parameters is
probably
seems to me an important part of using
this model
no no it's a great point actually me and
chris we're just talking about this like
like yesterday or something right like
how to design an optimal task to
disambiguate but include both having to
solve
problems that involve state and
parameter exploration simultaneously
technically the example model that we
have for the tutorial
is able to do that um but not
in an incredibly interesting way uh
justin justin kind of way to show that
how you could do it very interesting
about the experimental design because
the kind of statistical techniques like
a t-test
we know the statistical power
calculations or we might know the kinds
of experimental designs
that lead to good clean t-tests but it's
a great point about the experimental
design
and just to highlight this generalizable
and also generative
nature we talked about a lot of
different areas of research a lot of
different frameworks
but the parts that stood out to me were
christopher you said decision making
under uncertainty
and action and perception that covers a
lot a lot of different areas of
neuroscience
and then we are looking for this kind of
unified explanation
but rather than an explanation which
might be philosophical or based upon how
much we understand it or how we feel
that one day
we're rather going to look for a unified
computational
architecture or a computational paradigm
as you said
that will let us compare and design and
develop
these generative and generalizable
models so really
cool discussion and i'm just going to
ask one question from the youtube live
chat then we'll go to ryan with a screen
share
cb asks can active inference research
help us understand the neuroscience of
stimulus independent thoughts when there
isn't any sensory input at all
thanks for elaboration in this regard
i mean i guess i mean the broader answer
would say yes
but um the way that you would do it
would probably be
pretty task specific um you know so
so i'm um i'm not necessarily sure how
to give a really precise detailed answer
without knowing the particular like task
or even just general psychological
context
that's being imagined um so i mean it's
actually
really easy to model for instance like
working memory tasks
where you might get a stimulus at one
point but then there's no stimulus for a
really long time
and somehow the thing has to continue to
maintain representations
um in the absence of any stimulus to
know what to do you know at some
distant future point um um you know
just there's that kind of thing um i
mean just as one example i
again i like i said it the way to answer
the question is probably is
it would be different depending on the
exact sort of psychological or task
context in question
cool so just like explore exploit there
are tasks that looked more exploratory
or more exploitative
almost within this action of perception
we're going to be talking about some
tasks that
are more towards the action-oriented
side like the policy planning or the
motor behavior
and other tasks that are more towards
almost the perceptive side like this
visual awareness
task now ocular motor movement the
movement of the eye muscles is still a
behavior
and there's papers that model that but
it's almost like we're looking at the
whole spectrum of explore exploit or
action perception reinforcement learning
and wondering how we can
again make this unified framework for
talking about these different kinds of
systems
so shall we jump right in ryan or go
ahead anything else
well i mean unless i mean just just one
last point to bring up in relation to
their you know this person's question is
just that it's actually
what's really important and probably a
more recent development and this is
stuff that um some of the visual
awareness stuff that me and chris have
done and also
um some stuff uh that i've done
previously with like emotional awareness
for example like models of emotional
awareness
um there's there's a really important
sense of what you're doing
not just behavioral actions but actually
cognitive
actions um right so you're selecting
policies that
just do something like in the neural
implementation just do something like
change the the functional connectivity
between two brain regions or or change
in other words it is stimulus
independent uh
action they're actions that that have to
do with changing what you're doing
cognitively and not what you're doing
behaviorally
um you know so that's also an important
uh part of it that's been done in
you know a few previous papers that um i
think
uh relates an important way to this kind
of stimulus independence sort of
question um but again only if i
understood it right
cool good answer and thanks for that so
go ahead and
share your screen and just however we
can help whatever you want us to do or
not do we're there but i'm really
looking forward to this
okay so the um you know the main
the main thing here that i want to do
just to start as you know and this is in
part just because i'm assuming that not
everyone who's watching today was
watching
uh last week um so i'm not going to be
able to give you
a full understanding of where we're sort
of of how we're segueing from last week
to this week but i just want to give
kind of like a really sort of uh rapid
overview of where we're kind of going um
you know so first we covered this slide
here
which just um shows an example of how
you can do
um how you can do perception as bayesian
inference
and then and this is just an example a
mathematical example of how it works
um but the idea is where you're you see
this sort of two-dimensional image
and you're this gray thing under great
disc under observation you're trying to
infer
based on prior expectations whether it's
a
three dimensionally it's a concave or
convex shape
and so the idea is is that in simple
problems you can do that exactly by
solving
um bayes theorem so this equation up
here on the upper left
but in most cases that's actually
intractable to do
and so what you do in active inference
is you instead um define this thing
f here which is called expected free
energy
um and it's more or less
a measure of the accuracy of predictions
minus
the accuracy of beliefs and combined
with the complexity
of those beliefs essentially how much
you have to change your beliefs to
to get a model that's accurate so by
finding
a set of beliefs that minimize
expected free energy in other words ones
that are accurate
while changing as little as possible um
this is just an example of how by doing
that
by just kind of searching around for
different qs's here
different beliefs about the probability
of states
then you can find one that when you
calculate it gives the lowest value for
f and that's going to be the one that's
as close as possible
to the true uh answer the bayes theorem
would give you
um and so uh
so what you're um i'll kind of skip this
one but
well so what you're trying to do then an
active inference is you have some true
thing going on out in the world true
states and the observations that they
generate
um but then the brain has this model
where it's trying to say okay
what state must i be in given that
i got this observation so the brain is
trying to essentially
come up with the representation that
best matches
what's going on in the generative
process in other words the thing that's
truly generating the observations
um and so that's probability of
o and s so states and observations this
pi thing is policies
so it's what's the most likely action i
ought to choose
given that the world is this way and
given that i prefer some observations
over others
and what's going to be important for
what i cover
today is the way that you actually
set up these generative models
and the way that these are set up is you
have these states
s and you have these observations o um
and then you have prior initial prior
expectations
that we just called d um
and if you solve this right if you get
some observations
and you say given my generative model
what states are most likely
given those observations and given my
prior expectations d
then you get your sort of optimal belief
about what the
what the states ought to be given those
observations
but in active inference we do this in a
way that's also dynamic
so for instance states at one at time
one
are going to transition into states at
time two
and so you also have beliefs this thing
in b
about what states are most likely to
transition into what other states
um and then um
and this is kind of one of the unique
moves in active inference is that
policies so the different action
sequences you might choose
are just models as things that entail
different transitions between states
so b matrix 1 for example here would
entail
choosing to move from one state to
another state whereas some different
policy would entail a different b matrix
that means you transition
from one state to some other state
and the choice of policy depends
on g here which is the expected free
energy which is a function of
c which is your preferences so
essentially what you're trying to do is
you're trying to find the policy
which corresponds to a set of state
transitions
that will generate the observations over
time
that are going to be as consistent as
possible with uh your preferences which
corresponds to having the lowest
g um and so and then there's
some other sort of parameters up here
that can say
add habits so e here can give you kind
of an additional prior over policies
that
gives you kind of habits to do one thing
over another it can have this
beta gamma thing that also controls how
uh precise or how reliable um
the model expects uh the expected free
energy estimates to be
um so i realize that's a lot um but we
kind of covered this
more slowly last time
but what you really need to know um when
we're actually putting together the code
like i'm going to walk you through
this is what we're going to be
specifying step by step we're going to
be specifying what the observations are
um we're going to be specifying the
likelihood a
so in other words what states generate
what observations with what probability
we're going to be specifying d and b
which are the
priors of our initial states and beliefs
about how states are going to transition
um and we're going to define policies
this pi
thing which is going to tell us the
different possible
state transitions we could choose um and
then we're going to find
c here which is what the agent's
preferences are what observations
it wants to get over others um
as well as the habits and this beta
thing the expected
free energy precision so
building a model in the code amounts to
just specifying
what all these things are what the state
space is what the observation
space looks like what a and d and b look
like
and what c looks like and maybe e and
beta and so if you want to know the
exact equations for solving this
um you know we've shown them here but
again i'm not gonna
describe them in detail um but basically
all they're doing is they're saying
given my beliefs about state transitions
so my priors
and given a my likelihood what's my most
likely posterior belief going to be
which is just bayesian inference right
priors and likelihoods together
equal posteriors um or
are approximate to posteriors
technically um
but so that's what we're doing
we're going to make one comment on that
slide ryan yeah
yes so on the top left we have state
inference given priors and given
observations so that's kind of inference
and we're going to be building on the
strata
to go from inference bayesian inference
to
active inference so you go from the top
left which is just
perception at one moment in time that's
static to the bottom
left where you have states that are
updating through time
given priors and given observations
you're updating your estimate through
time
then you go to the top right so that so
the bottom left square adds in time
now on the top right we add in this
element of policy selection or control
theory
and then on the bottom right we get all
the way up to this full active inference
model which not just has a control
theory element through policy
but some extra parameters that help us
as we're going to find out soon like e
and beta
so just to give that one more time
because this is what's unique about
active inference
and this is the skeleton of the model
that everything else is going to be
scaffolded onto
thanks ryan continue yeah no thank you
that was definitely a good
uh quicker uh clear summary um
so appreciate it um okay so
and then again just to remind people the
end goal of all of this is to learn how
to put together
um particular generative models right
particular sets of
a matrices d vectors b matrices c
matrices etc for
empirical so for behavioral tasks that
participants can do and then you can fit
these models
to actual behavior to learn things
about participants for instance you
might learn
what their parameters are for a or for b
or for instance what their beta value is
um you know etc um so
that's the that's the kind of ultimate
goal here
but the kind of first step to do that
beyond just understanding the structure
i was talking about
is to know how to actually put that
together in the code
and so last time you know i gave a bunch
of examples
of past experiments that we and others
have done where we have built
active inference models for tasks fit
them to data and
learn things for instance about
differences in
substance use and learning rates for
example or differences in beta and
decision uncertainty
in between healthy people and people
with depression and anxiety or substance
use um or differences in um perception
of uh precision of precision estimates
for
uh interceptive perception for instance
um
you know so so i just kind of went
through these examples
of specific tasks and empirical results
just to show the kind of thing that you
can do with this in practice
and but um and then the the task that
we're
modeling is one that's designed to be
really simple but
that also kind of showcases um
the major important elements of active
inference models
um and so here what we're doing is we
have a task
where the agent starts in a start state
and they can either directly choose to
pull the left to choose the left slot
machine or the right slot machine
and if they do that they can either win
four dollars or zero dollars depending
on which machine is better
the left one or the right one but they
don't know ahead of time which one's
better so they can either kind of
take a risky guess and either get four
dollars or zero
or they can choose to seek information
first to ask for this hint
and the hint will tell them which uh the
left one which of the left one of the
right one is better
on that trial um and if it's the left
better
context that means the left one will win
80 of the time
and if the hint says the right one's
better then the right one will
pay out 80 of the time but there's a
cost
to taking the hint which is that if you
take the hint and then choose a machine
then you can only win two dollars
instead of four um so that's
what we're going to be modeling um and
so what we need to specify for that is
we need to specify
that there are two types of hidden
states one is
whether it's the left better or the
right better context whether it's a left
better or a better trial
and also the behavior states so choosing
to move from the start state to the hint
state
or choosing to move from the start state
directly to the
left or right slot machine
so that's two types of states um we have
to specify
the observations where in this case
the major observations are winning the
four dollars two dollars or zero dollars
um or in this case we're actually just
gonna model you win or you don't win and
i'll show you how that works
um and um
and we'll have to define uh the agent's
preferences so essentially saying it
prefers four dollars more than two
dollars and two dollars more than zero
dollars and that's going to be that
c thing um so
uh so that's kind of the general task
structure
and i went through um
you know the way to do this kind of
simply outside of the code which is
you define your initial state priors you
define your state outcome mapping
you define your preference outcome
preferences over outcomes
you define the state transitions slash
actions
um so b and then you define the policies
which you define as
this letter of v um and then the final
thing i'll talk about before going into
the code
is that in these models you can separate
out
the generative process so it's actually
out in the world generating observations
from the generative model which is the
agent's beliefs
about what's generating the observations
um and if we want to separate those in
the code
then what we do is big d or big a
um or big b um those are the generative
process
um but if you also specify a little d
or a little a or a little b then that's
the generative
model so that's the agent's beliefs and
if you specify those then they will be
separate
from the generative process and that's
typically what you need to do
that is what you need to do if you want
to model learning which uh i'll show
ryan just just two two quick points so
first off
um someone has asked will these slides
be available
or is there any resource where we can
look at these slides because there's a
lot of great information
on them um i can make them available
everything everything here is i mean
almost all the figures that i'm showing
um other than the actual task figure
here are
in the are in the tutorial paper and um
everything i'm showing about how to
actually build the models is is in the
code and well explained in the code like
i'll show
um but i'm also happy to provide you
know these
slides i mean just just let me know um
like i said the vast majority of them
are literally just the figures in the
paper
um so uh so yeah i mean like i said i'm
happy to make them available or send
them
um to anyone i could even just put them
as supplementary
additional supplementary material at the
tutorial as well so i mean yeah just
whatever whatever people want great idea
and what a
fun and accessible science we can have
when we just
receive questions like that and can put
up our slides and then i think max there
was a
question that you had about the b matrix
just while we're defining our
terms what would you like to say about
that
all right so uh but just real quick uh
for anybody who's just jumping in on the
stream
the link is is below the video you can
go to their paper if you're looking for
that supplementary code it's in the
supplementary materials you can download
all of the code from their supplementary
materials there
the question i had was um one thing to
touch on is as we walk through the code
one thing i noticed is that we have kind
of a tensorial structure
for these matrices um where
we could also specify a transition
matrix that was that had like a 2d
structure
with you know d with with probability of
0.8 0.2 but instead we have a tensorial
structure where we have
a fixed probability of one for
transitioning from any given state
to another state and i just thought uh
if you wanted to touch on maybe the
motivation for that i i
believe it's related to how the model
like basically interpreting the model
and
and and how the model gets used um
is that uh i don't know if you wanted to
elaborate on that any
yeah i mean i mean yes i mean so
technically you know we call these
things like that we call like
a matrix to the b matrix matrices but
technically they're tensors
um so they're high dimensional matrices
um
and um so so and
you know obviously go through this when
we go through the code but
because you can have different um types
of states
right so the state of being in the left
better or the right better context
versus the type of state that has to do
with you know where you move to or what
you choose right the
being in a start state versus the hint
state versus you know the left or right
bandit or yeah slot machine choice state
um because you have two different types
of states those are called state factors
and so essentially what you need to do
is you need to
specify these matrices or like i said
really tensors
that again this is for a that
say um what outcomes for each type of
outcome will be generated
for each combination of each value for
each state factor
um you know which makes which makes it
um
you know higher dimensional um which is
probably the trickiest part i'll explain
this as well as i
as i can when we go through the code um
but so but so that's that's that and
also so simultaneously because you have
two um types of states here that also
means you have to have
a b matrix a transition matrix for each
um type of state um
and when you when the agent doesn't have
control
about state about transitions for a
certain state um
then there's only going to be one of
these
uh b matrices um
so for example here so this just says b
for factor one which is what context
you're in
um this is just a simple uh 2d
matrix um although technically for
reasons in the code you define it as a
as a three-dimensional thing with just a
one here this is just
but that's just because the third
dimension here defines the
the number label for the action um
so this is basically just saying there's
only one action
for state factor one and that is
an identity matrix here which just means
that for each trial
it's gonna be the left better context
through the whole trial
right in other words within a trial it's
not gonna like after they take the hint
it's not gonna like switch on them you
know so really the right one is better
if they got the hint that the left one
was better
this is just saying if you start in the
left better one you're going to stay in
the left better one the whole trial
and that's it whereas
for stay factor two so the b matrices
for state factor two
um there are four of these which
correspond to four different possible
actions
um so here the third dimension says this
is action one
which means that from any state which
are the columns
you can move to state 1 which is the
first row
whereas the second one says if i pick
action 2
so third dimension value 2 then i can
move from any of the four states
again columns 2 state 2 which is the
hint state
and so forth for action 3 and action 4
moving to
choose the left bandit or the left
machine
or choosing the right machine so these
are going to be the four
actions which are just the four possible
transitions
um and then when you specify policies
this thing in v this is just saying for
each state factor
which of those actions can i string
together
um so v for
one here for state factor one is just a
bunch of ones because again
there's only one action it just stays in
whatever state it started in
um and each column here is a policy and
each row is a time
is a an action time point basically so
this is saying
so the first row here is what action
could i take
when moving from time one to time two
and the
third row and the second row here is
what action could i take when moving
from time to time
three and again each of these columns
just says stay in ones because there is
no
possible action for uh
changing the context but
policy the policy for a space for data
or for
factor two here um so again the the
actions
um there's these five columns and this
just says
i can move to the start state and i can
stay in the start state right so that's
just
action one up here twice um then the
second column here says
i could take action two so look at the
hint
and then yeah
and then uh move to
action three which is choose the left
machine or i could take the hint two
and then choose four which is move to
the right machine or i can go straight
to the right machine
and then go back to start or i can go
straight
to the or straight to the sorry three is
the left machine or straight to the
right machine
action four and then go back to start so
so in other words
you know there's a bunch of other
possible transitions right strings that
you might think of right you might
for instance go to the left machine and
then go take the hint or something like
that but we're not allowing that we're
saying
these are the allowable transitions so
these are the different policies
or action sequences that can be chosen
so correct me if i'm wrong but it seems
that this tensorial structure kind of
allows us to compress
all those different combinatorial you
know combinations that we might have so
it allows
the structure of basically just allows
the code to be a little more efficient
is that
at the end of the day yeah that's a
perfectly reasonable way to talk about
it
um so so okay so so that already gives
you kind of a
little bit of a start here um so now
um um and then and then in
so at the end of the day what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
specifying
each of these things so t the amount of
time steps v the policy space
a the likelihood the state outcome
mapping
b the transition probabilities or
transition matrices
c which is the preferred uh observations
this is preferred states here but it
should be preferred observations
um d it would be the priors of our
initial states
um and then all these other extra little
parameters that you
can or cannot include i'll talk about
those later
um but then we also specify this little
d which basically says the thing doesn't
start out knowing the context
so it has to learn the context over
trials it has to sort of build up
beliefs about d
over trials um so
with that as a kind of quick background
um
i'm going to now kind of move into the
code
it's cool that the whole thing is stored
as one
object with a bunch of fields because
it's almost like you could have
ensembles of these different models or
you might have a bunch of ants in a
colony
it really lends itself to being
reproducible and transparent
with what each parameter is and
comparing a whole host of them alongside
or different kinds of models
just really cool to see that instead of
just a tangle of parameters
that you can get lost in this is like a
column of things that each has a very
clear
purpose uh yeah so i should say so you
you do yeah put all these things into
the structure
that would usually just call little mvp
which just stands for markov decision
process
um and then when you actually run the
thing then you run it through
the uh the uh vb the spm mdp vb
underscore x
uh code and we've provided a version
that just
appends it with the word tutorial um
and you make that big mdp and then you
can take
use sub commands like this that just um
generate figures
that will show you the outcomes of the
the simulation
um and these are examples sort of
simulation results
but again i'll go into these after um we
go through some of the code
because to know how to actually use this
stuff you need to understand the code
um so hopefully i can make this not
too monotonous you know walking through
code isn't always the most exciting
but um the way that we have this set up
um is you know like i said we have
comments that kind of try our best to
explain what every little command means
you know like what clear and close
all mean what uh rng default means you
know etc
um i'm actually going to change this to
shuffle
and what that means is just that um the
matlab will use a random number
generator that um
won't do the exact same thing each time
so we can get
variable results when we run it
so we've provided um several different
simulation
options that we can use after building
the model below which is what i'll walk
through
so if you set the sim variable equal to
one
then that will just simulate a single
trial which will
reproduce uh figure seven um
in in the paper um so that'd just be a
single trial simulation
if you set sim equal to two then that'll
simulate multiple trials
um where the left context is always
active but um
the agent won't know that right the
agent has to learn okay the the
left one is the one it always is so
after a while it'll be confident and
won't
need to take the hint anymore um if i
could just briefly interject there so
that would be
for example an example of what we talked
about earlier as parameter exploration
yes uh well well not exactly it would be
an example
of learning the parameters over
successive um
yeah so state i mean state exploration
is a bigger thing here right because
either they choose to move to the queue
or not to learn which context it is yeah
i agree that so yeah the tricky thing is
is that when you only have two options
then
parameter exploration would just amount
to even though i've gotten some good
results from
choosing the left one
i might also instead try to choose the
right one a few times to be more
confident in what the
reward probability is for the right one
but typically to get good dynamics like
that you're probably
gonna need something that has um has
more like three arms
like three different options instead of
two
if you're also going to include the
state exploration thing with the q
um it would get a little more
complicated like a standard kind of
paradigm for doing parameter exploration
would be something where
you don't have the queue and the um the
agent just has like three choices
and it just kind of has to choose
different ones over time until it
becomes confident
which one is the best and then it'll
just keep choosing that one
so the parameter exploration would
amount to how many times kind of it
it chooses each slot machine initially
just to figure out which one is best um
and um a standard reinforcement learning
agent will do that differently
than an active inference agent um and
the the substance use study i mentioned
above actually specifically did that
um but uh but yeah so just one question
here
in this sim equals one two three four
five they're like
scenarios that you're going to be able
to rapidly
plug and play so scenario one is like a
static or scenario two is
multi-trial so this is what is going to
allow reproducible construction of the
figures
and understanding of how different
parameter changes influence behavior but
that's what we're laying out right now
it's kind of like the scenarios
for the agent right okay yeah i don't
know about it quick
is one thing i think sim five would take
about half an hour to run
yeah don't do it sim five we'll talk
about with when we talk about parameter
fitting which will be a different
session
um but mainly we'll be talking about sim
one two and three here which just has to
do with perception and learning
as opposed to the real empirical stuff
which is estimating parameters um
and uh you know using them you know
for group level analyses and things like
that well it's just so helpful though
how it's laid out
from the most static straightforward
perceptive
inference to action in the loop and then
now that action's in the loop
we're gonna think about the simplest
setting to explore action in a loop on a
single trial
unchanging and then we're going to keep
on adding layers of ecological
variability or other
features into the model so thanks for
making it so step wise and that's why
it's a step-by-step tutorial
yeah yeah we tried um but that's the
last thing for
for today so if you set sem equal to
three
then um that will simulate a reversal
learning uh situation
and that's where basically the left
context is active for a certain number
of trials
and so the agent should build up a prior
expectation that it's just the left one
every time
so it'll stop taking the hint and just
start choosing left
but then it switches and so now the
right context is the right one
is the correct one and you see basically
how long it takes
before the agent again says okay now i
need to start taking the hint again
and then eventually when it becomes
confident to just choosing the right one
you know directly um and not needing to
take the hint
um so it's kind of like a standard
reversal learning
kind of task um so those are the three
that hopefully we'll get through today
um and um there are several parameters
you know that can be kind of messed with
but the one that i've focused on mainly
here at least
we can set in the beginning is um this
rs1 thing which just turns into rs
later down um but that stands for risk
seeking or it could also be reward
seeking
um but more or less the bigger this
value is the
stronger the agent's preference is for
uh winning as much money as possible
so it's this is the value that's in the
c matrix that defines preferences
over winning versus losing um so the
bigger this number
the the more the agent
is going to say okay i care more about
reward than about information and
therefore i'm just going to take the
risky choice to go for
one of the slot machines directly so the
the higher this the less information
seeking the more
the lower this is the more the more
information seeking the agent will be
um and so that's just kind of a really
simple one
to show how by tweaking parameters you
can get different
results here just allowing you to weight
how strong the reward value component
is in the expected free energy versus
how
strong the weight is of the information
seeking component of the expected free
energy
um and then um you can kind of ignore
this
pebb thing down here this is basically
you can turn this on if when you do sim
equals five
you want to actually do group level
bayesian analyses on the parameters
um this will also save the outputs of
sim
like chris said sim 5 like takes like a
half hour to run
so if you turn this thing on it'll also
save
the results of sim 5 so you can run this
peb thing
without having to reduce m5 every time
um
so we just figured hopefully that would
help i just i just want to jump in and
point out that it's really nice in this
part where
for example with ourselves set there now
let's say that i'm designing my
experiment and i need to know how many
trials and how many
uh subjects do i need when i'm doing my
power analysis
i can run a simulation like this set
that parameter at what i think might be
a reasonable range of values from the
literature
and then i can say well this is the
expected difference in my groups based
on what i think this range of values
might be so it's a really powerful tool
to be able to plug and play a single
parameter like that
yeah i know it's nice i mean typically
with experimental you know with
experiments what you do want to do first
is you want to kind of see hey
can tweaking different parameters in the
model
produce simulated behavior that looks a
lot like the type of behavior i actually
see in
real participants um you know so
yeah so exactly you'd be hoping for is
hey like there's a chunk of people
that look like that act as though they
have a high risk seeking
value and another group of people they
have a lower
risk seeking value based on their
behavior
you can fit the model to that explicitly
and then you can say hey
is the difference in the rs value
between these two groups of people does
that predict anything interesting
you know does that tell you something
about you know how well they're going to
respond to like
drug a versus drug b or does it tell you
something about
um you know their general cognitive
ability or you know their current
emotional state or
you know like you can do all that kind
of stuff which is the ultimate goal of
all of this
um but so okay
so the first thing we need to do um at
least in the order i have it set up
is to set t so t is the number of time
steps in the trial
so in this case there are three time
steps remember because
the uh the agent
the agent has to start in the start
state and then
move to the second time step choose the
hint state
and then third time step choose one of
the machines
or it can go straight from the start
state to one of the machines
but then at the third time step it'll
just go back to the start state
that's how we have it set up anyway so
you need three time steps
um so then
um what's typically easiest is to first
out
start out by specifying the uh prior
expectations over states um and so in
the
in big d which is the generative process
for factor number one which is in the
braces here
we just specify this as a column vector
so a row and then this means that it's
transposed and becomes a column
this uh apostrophe thing here
and so we set this as one and zero which
just means
that it's with 100 probability gonna be
in the left better context
and then for the second state factor so
this d2
thing here we set it so the agent
always starts out in the start state so
a one in that first
entry and then zeros for all the rest
because it's never going to start
in the hidden state or in the choose
left state or in the choose right state
so we're just saying absolutely the
agent will always start in the start
state
but then and this is all explained but
then for
little d this is the agent's actual
beliefs we say
the agent has no idea what context it's
going to be
to start with so we set these to values
that are flat so where each uh the left
better and the right better context have
the same values
um but notice here that we didn't set
these up to add up to one
um like we did for big d i mean the
reason
is is that these are technically what
are called dirichlet distributions
um and dirichlet distributions um
are uh basically they say
um the smaller these numbers are the
less confident the agent
is um in its beliefs so if these are
0.25 and 0.25
it thinks it's a flat distribution but
it's really unconfident
whereas this thing was like 20 and 20
then
it would also believe it's a flat
distribution but it'd be really really
confident
that its beliefs are about a flat
distribution um
and to explain that better um i we're
actually going to transition over to
chris who's going to give you a little
bit of am a kind of more
general explanation of how learning
works here since you actually do need to
understand this now
um so we can transition over to chris
here briefly
yep because usually a probability people
would imagine it sums to one
something has to happen you know the
coin has to go heads or tails so it has
to add up to
100 has to add up to one to be a
classical probability
but this is a little bit of a tweak on
that some similar features but some
unique features so
thanks for switching over there and
helping us understand it
yep so can you guys see my screen yes we
don't see you but we see your screen all
right
go ahead all good okay
so as ryan was saying before essentially
our likelihood
what we were talking about before say
we're talking about the a matrix there
is technically speaking a
dirichlet so all of the distributions
will be categorical distributions our
d's
our b's and our a's they're all
categorical distributions
um and they all have a pro prior
or a distribution over the parameter
space which is a dirichlet distribution
um and so just kind of the people who
are technically like in the know as it
were uh
a categorical distribution is just a
special case of
a multinomial distribution
and a dirichlet distribution is what's
called a conjugate prior
for the categorical and the multinomial
distributions which just means that
if you multiply these two things
together these two distributions
you get out the distribution that has
the same form
as the prior and that's really important
if you're doing like
empirical bays for example where the
prior or
the posterior after round one serves as
the prior
in round the second round of inference
that kind of thing
um and so just to briefly go through
this so um
you guys can see my cursor right yep
yeah cool okay
this is the categorical distribution
where x is some
uh categorical variable that occupies
one of
one decay mutually exclusive states of
the world
that is to say say i have a distribution
over a grid world
where my agent is my agent can't be in
two places at once it's either in like
it's either left or it's right
for example um and theta are just the
parameters of that distribution
and so this function here this thing's
sticking out the front
is this normalization constant we can
adjust this it just counts the
combinatorics of the distribution and
assume and
ensures that sums to one exactly the
same thing here with the dirichlet
distribution
although it is a distribution over the
parameter space
of our likelihood right and so dirichlet
distributions often kind of colloquially
called distributions of distributions
um because they're a distribution over a
vector that has to sum to one
and then what's really beautiful about
these two distributions is that when you
multiply them together
and we'll just ignore the normalization
constant because things get pretty messy
but you end up with a distribution that
it has
at the same functional form as the prior
it's also a dirichlet distribution so
our posterior distribution
over the parameters of our likelihood is
also
a dirichlet distribution and all that
changes when we go from the prior
likelihood is we add to this little
alpha thing here it's called a count
so we essentially just add a count to
whatever it was that was observed to the
variable that was observed
so i'm just going to go into a little
bit more detail than that on the next
slide
is there anything you want to add to
that ryan um
no i mean just just i mean at the at the
end of the day and you know
chris will chris will cover this you
know i'm sure is that
while this might look really complicated
to somebody who doesn't have a lot of
math background it really just amounts
to
um they're being like what i showed you
with d there being a number
that's assigned to each entry um and
when you observe something
that number will get bigger um so that
just
means that um like what i said that
uh for instance if i believe that i was
in the
left better state the last five times
then
i'll add like five numbers
you know i'll add one five times to that
left one so now it would be like
5.25 as opposed to just 0.25
um and ultimately those numbers
get soft maxed so they just get
normalized and turned back into a
probability distribution
um but but like i said at the end of the
day you're just adding
counts each time you observe something
yeah
this is just like how you might be a
little bit more confident about the true
ratio of different kinds of colors of
balls in an urn if you had three of one
color and then one of the other color
you're not quite sure
if you had three million and one million
you'd be very sure
and then max you had a question yeah
so just going to the other end of the
spectrum then if i'm somebody
who's in probability theory and i'm
talking about a dirichlet distribution
and i'm talking about the support for
that distribution on the
open interval 0 1 and as we can see here
from these equations that are provided
uh that you know if i if i go to zero
then i'm basically going to end up with
a
since it's multiplying each time then
there could be problems so
in practice however uh my question
not being very experienced with using
these things in practice
when we implement this does that have
much of an effect on any of the
estimated parameters
um no but
one thing to say is that because you
always work with log
you we're always in log space we end up
once you just have basically a little
numerical trick where
all of your to make sure that you never
have a log of 0 we add
e to the negative 16 to all the entries
um does that kind of answer your
question
yeah so if for example if i see at the
end of the day
uh i might have a a converged parameter
that has apparently a very low
log likelihood of uh you know when i
when i converge on that estimate is it
you know maybe part of that could be
related to okay
there's some times where i'm entering in
a state that might be
unlikely to occur most of the time or
maybe it wasn't observed in this
particular set of experiments but the
rest of it kind of
holds up is that maybe one way to think
about low low
uh values uh when i converge to my
parameter estimates
um i'm not sure i totally understand the
example just because it's a bit a little
bit abstract could we give it
how about the the slot machine example
it's like you go into the casino you've
never done any of the slot machines
it's like you haven't had much
experience so even if you're
um not sure about which one's better
it's like you're not sure
overall and then as you try more of the
slot machines just like ryan was saying
you increment up observations so to
speak in those columns
so after you've made a thousand slot
machine visits you're a little bit more
confident than after you had made
zero or one or few is that the case just
to bring it to the example
that we're gonna be sure yeah or i could
pull the slot machine three times and
get
only one result observed and i would
never have um
the complement to that result observed
and so then effectively my my
probability distribution is
then one and zero on my posterior um
so if i end up having like weird looking
numbers
in my on my converged parameter
estimates in terms of the log
likelihoods for the different things
it's kind of maybe just relates to this
particular property but at the end of
the day
what it sounds like is that i'm still
going to converge to the correct values
using this
approach that's just like kind of an
insurance um
yeah i'm not sure honestly about any if
there are any formal results that relate
to this
um but in practice because
we always basically the categorical
distribution is just and
it just ends up being a soft max
function over the concentration
parameters
um you'll always have something that's
between zero and one
um and the concentration parameters are
basically will always kind of be
somewhere between
zero if it's never been observed and
at whatever it is it goes to however
high your
however many experiments you run or
simulations you run
um i've never encountered a problem with
this
but then again i've never actually
really looked into
um possible consequences of
that so i just don't know i'm sorry ryan
do you ever think so um i mean the only
thing i would say
yeah and maybe maybe i misunderstood the
question but i mean if it has to do with
whether or not you'll
there's certainly no guarantee that
you'll converge on the
on the uh on the true generative process
yeah there's there's lots of cases where
things can go wrong and you'll get stuck
in local minima and things like that
um we actually show several examples of
that in this uh structure learning
paper um where we show how you can use
how you can use active inference for
structure learning and um
like bayesian model expansion or state
space expansion and safe space
production and things like that
there's lots of cases where you'll
end up with the wrong likelihood um
so so it's not uh yeah it's
or maybe in my mind just a caveat would
then be
you know if going to that example with
the posterior distribution i only have
uh pulled the or picked a machine three
times
um when we're designing our experiment
it might be important to consider
setting it up so that
you know we're not going to get into the
case where we only have a sample of n of
three because obviously that doesn't
sound like good science to anybody
anyways but
it's just kind of the oversimplified
case where as you add more categories
you could run into that scenario for one
of your particular categories which
could cause some problems
it sounds like if there's a hundred
kinds of cereal and you only
let people choose one time you're not
going to get a good estimate it's kind
of like a
sample size and an experimental design
question
so just to kind of pull back for those
because that's that's a
really interesting question about where
there's probability or
how different sample sizes are related
to each other but
we're just thinking about this the
structure for how
additional observations are going to
increase
the kind or the the quality of this
estimate of a parameter yeah and you'll
and you'll see and what
and what chris shows you that that um
like the
basically the the lower the
concentration val the concentration
priority values are
generally the more the expected free
energy will be weighted
toward um choosing like uh parameter
exploration policies
right so it'll be a thing where if it's
never chosen the
99th serial before it'll be driven to go
choose that one
just because it wants to be more
confident in what the actual parameters
are
but but anyway i uh crystal yeah go go
ahead
yeah yeah so we actually don't yeah we
actually don't have any numerical
examples in the paper where we
kind of have show the free energy values
um for different parameter
values we only kind of have state
exploration
terms but um there are i mean
maybe that's something we could add to
the paper actually that would be
something interesting
yeah people yeah okay
so essentially just to kind of give a
little recap we just have
our uh our
probability distribution over a or the
parameters of a is just a dirichlet
distribution
over kind of over a and then so we
just end up with a matrix that has
the number right where the rows are our
possible observations
and the columns are our hidden states
and
literally all that we're doing this so
this little term this little kind of
cross inside a circle is called a
kronecker tensor product
um actually that goodness is that
correct i actually don't know
that's the notation cross product
it's in the spm textbook that notation
is used for the chronicler
product yeah thank you okay good um
sorry i just had a brief mind blank i
was like oh god anyway so and this eta
thing here is just a learning rate and
so whatever it will just multiply
essentially this here so say i'll just
give an example
and we'll just add that to our previous
values of whatever these a's are so just
very simply say we have our posterior
over states
is something like 0.7.3 and
our op we receive observation so this is
a
transpose vector so this corresponds to
row 2. this all that this would do is
we're literally adding
a value of 0.7 and 0.3 to
this matrix that's all that learning is
really it's very simple um and then
both of these things will get both of
these uh columns will get passed through
a softmax function at the end of the day
and just kind of give
a give an example of what we're talking
about before so because they're both
soft maxed
all that soft all soft max cares about
is
that the difference between the two
numbers in
all the two elements of the vector so 51
and 50 and two and one
the same same value in the softmax but
in one case the model is incredibly
confident and in the other case it's not
confident at all
for example so if you had an agent that
was actually doing parameter exploration
there would be no the agent would have
no motivation whatsoever
to explore the parameters in the first
case of 5150 but it would be quite
motivated in the case of two one
for example even though the likelihood
distribution you end up getting out of
that
is the same okay good
um so that is actually i think all that
we really had that's all that i'd
prepared for this is because
it's really is in practice it's so
simple
um so back to you ryan okay
sorry
okay so anyway with that as a little bit
of the background
always all we're doing here is we're
saying to start with the agent believes
it's a flat distribution it has no idea
which one's going to be better
left or right on each trial that's in
little d because that's our model
so each time it believes that it was in
the left better context it's just going
to keep adding
you know numbers to this 0.25 here
and those will be scaled by the learning
rate thing that uh
that um chris showed where uh you know
if
if learning rate is one then each time
it observes the left better context
it'll just add a one so it'll become
1.25 and then 2.25
etc but if the learning rate was like
0.5
so it was like lower then it would add
each time so it'd be 0.75 1.25
etc so the learning rate just scales how
big the counts are they get added
um and the learning rate could be zero
at which case there wouldn't be an
updating just
thinking about just what could the whole
range be from
not a learning agent to very slowly
incorporating new information
using this dirichlet framework that
christopher just described
all the way up to just ridiculously high
values so that
it just yeah i should just highlight as
well i think there's this is
i just kind of want to this probably
isn't a good point for discussion just
to keep things moving but one thing
that's worth highlighting is there's a
genuine kind of
debate or maybe debates a bit too strong
word but discussion to be had
about whether we should actually be
moduling modulating learning rate
given that the model is bayes optimal or
approximately bayes optimal one would
assume that there should be a way of
modeling things without actually
changing the learning rate from one
um but in practice i'm not sure if that
actually works but
anyway so yeah so i mean i mean
technically technically a learning rate
of one is optimal
yeah but for but for um
for when you're fitting behavior when
you're fitting the model to behavior
um most people are not
optimal um and so uh you have to
estimate
typically the learning rate for each
person
and oftentimes it's quite a bit below
one but that's actually an interesting
attribute and again it's an example
about how using these generative
and generalizable frameworks help us
compare not just
who could remember more numbers or who
had a faster reaction time
as far as just observable
characteristics we're moving a step back
and asking whether
people might differ in their learning
rate or in other attributes of this
model
yeah and there's also and again i mean
this isn't something to really get into
so much but
there is effectively a learning rate
that comes out of the
precision of your posterior beliefs over
states
um like for instance if your posterior
beliefs over states are really imprecise
like say it's like point say afterwards
you know this is like
0.6.4 then whatever observation that you
get
is just going to add counts of 0.6 and
0.4
which means that you're not really going
to build up
strong priors um you know uh
um a straw a more precise prior for one
over the other
um because uh you're you're not
confident about which state you're in
just a quick
example of that you go into the casino
and you're drawn a card
and you can't read the card or it's the
number is rubbed off so if there's no
precision at the sensory level
with which card you drew you're not
going to be updating
your estimate of how likely different
numbers are and then if there's a
perfectly legible card
so it's 100 you have no error about
which card it is
there's the secondary question about how
much you update your internal
model but it's not a precision about the
perception
question so it's really a nice point and
it's worth
understanding that you can have
uncertainty about observations
that then is captured by this model but
also
even in the case of precise or even
totally observable scenarios
there's additional uncertainty related
to learning
yeah i mean again there's still
potential problems i mean what tends to
happen in these models is especially if
learning rate is one then like
the agent kind of becomes too confident
too quickly
or or a better way to put it as they
once they've like observed a certain
number of like
lefts for example becomes really hard
for it to
unlearn that um which is different from
what humans do
humans tend to infer that there's a
different context like okay no now it's
the
now it's a new context where right is
better so it doesn't necessarily unlearn
the original uh counts
it instead sort of infers now i'm in a
new state and i need to accrue
different counts for that state um and
that requires more complex
models which can also be built just but
couple couple little notes that that's
kind of like humans using narrative
to help reset local parameter
estimations like oh well now it's a new
day
so now things that were unlikely
yesterday now it can be likely today
and also it relates to this question
about the optimal learning rate in a
mathematical or an analytical framework
maybe one or
some other number is quote optimal but
then in a realized
ecological setting it might be actually
not
the best solution in that setting
yeah um so i mean yeah typically people
talk about this in other literature as
being like laden cause inference or leia
like inferring the latent causes um
behind things there's different latent
cause it's kind of the same thing as
saying there's a different context and
therefore a different likelihood
um but uh but yeah so so i'll just kind
of you know go through this here you
know kind of step by step so
you know so i so i'm gonna set up right
so i have
um i have my big d and my little d
here um and then the next thing i'm
going to do
is i'm doing this a little bit you know
condensed is to just
set the number of states here for each
state factor so that's going to be the
length of d1 and the length
of d2 so this one's going to be the two
contacts so there's going to be two
states
and this one's going to be the length of
d2 which is going to be four states
so at the end of the day this ns thing
if you look on the right
is just going to look like that 2 and 4.
just one
note there for those who are unfamiliar
with matlab so at line 148 where ns
is you put a little red dot like a stop
sign and then
you hit run which ran everything that we
had just discussed from a clean slate
up to that line and then it halted so
that's what allowed us to actually
instantiate all these variables we were
just talking about
and then you stepped just one line at a
time
so that you could run this line 148 with
all of its prerequisites fulfilled so
it's kind of like a break point in the
program
we took a breath and then we ran one
line and so now we're going to go step
by step
yeah it just allows you to kind of see
what it's doing step by step which is
yeah it's helpful so sorry
i should have said what plays and step
and stuff like that um
so so now that i've specified that i can
put this little for loop thing which
just says
um for that for i equals one to the
number of states
for factor two um i'm just going to make
it all
the no hint this is just saying for all
the matrices
in a1 to start with um
everything is just going to generate the
no hint observation
um so it will end up just looking
like this where uh
right so i just have so this is just
saying um and i should say that
the columns correspond to the first day
factor so
left context right context and these
third the third
dimension here one two three four that's
what corresponds to the
second state factor which is the um
the behavior so this is saying
when i'm in the start state one each
context
is going to generate the no hint
observation when i'm in the hint stay
factor
it's going to generate the no hint
observation and so forth so i'm just
starting it that way
for ease to say that they're all that
way but then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to define this thing pha
which is the probability
of the hint being accurate
and again this is just kind of to make
things uh
a little bit concise and convenient and
then i'm going to replace
that a2 because remember a2 means i'm in
the hint state
um and so i'm going to say when i'm in
column one in column one here
i'm gonna observe the machine left hint
with some probability if i'm in the
machine left state which is the left
column
and then one minus that for the no hint
state
and again if i'm in the right the right
better
context so the the right column here
then it's going to be the reverse
i'm going to observe the right machine
with some probability
just one one note on that ryan so people
might look at this and wonder why didn't
you just say hint or no hint instead of
this one minus one equals zero
and this is because as you've had it it
generalizes to cues
that are less than a hundred percent
accurate so then you could have the
probability of the hint being accurate
to being 90 or less or some other value
and so if you have a probabilistic
learning task you can model it
with this exact framework just by
changing pha equals
point something rather than reimagining
the entire
matrix multiplication which is really
the hard part
yeah exactly so so if i step through
that then in this case i've set pha to 1
which just means the hint is completely
accurate
so now if i look at a1 again
then it's going to look like this where
all the other
behavioral states so in the start state
in choosing the left state or choosing a
left machine and choosing the right
machine
they those still generate row one here
both of both contacts do because the no
hint
but if i'm in state two which is the
hint behavioral state then if i'm in the
left machine
or if i'm in the left state then i will
observe
the left is better hint um with
probability one and if i'm in the right
column here the right
context is better state then i'm going
to observe
the right hint observation so the bottom
row here
with 100 probability so in other words
if i observe this thing then i'm going
to know for sure
that i i'm now in the left better
context
um but if again if i made this like
0.8.2.2
then that would just mean you know
there's some probability that the hints
gonna
give me the wrong answer um so that's
so that's all that is so remember the
first state factor is the columns the
second state factor
is going to be the third dimension
that's kind of key
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to define the
second output modality so this is
another thing that's important
is that the uh the number here for a
that's in the braces that corresponds to
the outcome
modality um so the first
set of observations i can get is
no hint machine left hint and machine
right hint
so that's one set of observations that
we call like an observation or an
outcome modality
um now for a two the second
observation or outcome modality the
possible observations
are null loss
and win um so what this is saying
is for the first two behavioral states
for i equals one and two
um the uh so being in the start state or
the hint state is always going to
generate
the null observation so it's not going
to generate a loss or a win
now after that if i step through here
i can set what i just called p win so
the probability of winning
and i set that to be 0.8 and this is the
part where the actual reinforcement or
reward learning
comes in um because what i can do
is i can say okay if i'm in
the left choose the left machine state
so
3 then
the probability of winning the
probability of losing
is 1 minus
p win and the probability of winning in
the right one
or the probability of losing in the
right one if i choose the right one
is high right which makes sense right
because if i'm in the left better
context
then if i choose the right column right
if i choose the right
machine then i'm most likely going to
lose
in contrast if i'm in the
right better context
and i choose uh if i choose the right
machine and i'm in the right better
context
then the right column here should
generate a win
with high probability this is just
saying if i choose the right machine
that's the four and i'm in the right con
right better context which is the right
column
then i have a high probability of
winning
and vice versa up here if i choose the
left one
again just to talk about how this is the
minimal example we're talking about
two options with the two slot machines
there could be more options
we're talking about how much it costs to
get the hint and how much it costs when
you win or how much you receive when you
win
that's a parameter you can change how
accurate the hint is you could have a
perfectly accurate hint that sends you
to the slot machine
that wins 100 of the time so the
probability of winning
can now be changed so then you can say
okay i'm imagining a situation where
there's a perfect messenger with a hint
and then it's free to visit that person
and then it's 100 likely which slot
machine is the winning one
or you can imagine these more gray zone
scenarios where different things are
associated with each other in a less
direct way or there's more than two
options
just for those who are like seeing this
one example for the first time
this is kind of like the tip of the
iceberg of a big big family of different
kinds of models that have a lot more
options and a lot more nuance
yeah i mean you could have you know 20
outcome modalities and
10 state factors if you wanted to it
would just mean that like there'd be a
fourth dimension for the third state
factor and a fifth dimension for the
fourth state factor and you know it'll
just get really big really fast
um but so now that i've done this
because i set the probability of winning
to 2.8
um given that you're you know in the
correct
context then a2 will look like this
so this just says if i choose
if i'm in the start state i don't
observe a i never observe a win or a
loss if i'm in the hit state
i never observe a win or a loss um
if i'm if i choose the left option
the left machine then i will win with
point eight
and lose with 0.2 and the opposite
for if i choose the right one right i'll
lose with 0.8 if i
if i choose the left machine and i'm in
the right
context and if i choose the right
machine
so state 4 here then the probability of
winning
is point eight so the third row here is
winning right
um and point two and vice versa so this
is just defining the probability of
winning
given your choice given whether it's the
left better or write better context
um and i know that's a mouthful but uh
yeah um so then finally
um and you know this isn't really all
that practically interesting
but it's important to include is is that
what this just says
um so outcome modality three is just the
agent's own behavior
so what this means is every single time
it makes a choice it observes itself
making that choice and all that does is
make the agent completely confident
about what it did um but you could
imagine
if somebody weren't aware of their own
decision-making behavior
you could imagine that might lead to
decision-making that's not in line with
what you would do if you could observe
your behavior
yeah so you know i mean if you if you
get rid of this then in some cases the
agent
yeah won't be all that confident what he
did and so therefore it'll be hard for
him to
uh hard to learn what actions were the
right one because we won't know like
what it shows basically
uh it'd be like choosing a slot machine
blind um
i just want to jump in with a question
about my
motor systems context so for example if
i'm studying sensory motor integration
and i'm measuring motor cortex signals
from neurons and motor cortex
and i'm measuring uh outputs such as the
kinematics
the kinetic forces that are generated
and the emg signals in the periphery
i could then use that that context to
say
i could specify it as either one one or
a zero one for example if i didn't
think that it was a capable observing
its past history or
its its decision states in the form of
some kind of a sensory blockade
uh related to my experiments would that
be a practical application would does
that
have face validity in this context given
that i'm measuring those signals
uh one thing that just collect with flag
generally speaking in motor control
domains you're working with like
continuous quantities right
right and that's why you use things like
kalman filters etc
as your models um i'm not sure to what
extent
a partially observable markov decision
process would actually be the
appropriate generative model for the
situation
i think it would be if you want to model
like the decision making processes
observ for motor control
so am i going to move my arm to left or
the right that is a discrete decision
but actually measuring motor control and
a lot of those things that you're
talking about those continuous signals
i'm not actually sure p o mdp is the
appropriate generative model
but for example if i thought that i had
a state space that consisted of a
a fixed point or any kind of you know
however i'm abstracting those continuous
processes into the realm of you know a
discrete state
uh just glossing over that
this kind of model could maybe uh
account for that
or do you usually use in that way in any
i mean in any case you know where where
signal is technically continuous
i mean you know to use these sorts of
models right you're going to have to
just pick some
quasi-arbitrary or maybe justify in some
sense
a way to kind of bin you know bin time
right you'd have to desperatize
time in some in some way um you know the
signal was
x for these three milliseconds and now
it changed to y
these next three milliseconds that'd be
some kind of like funny average or
something like that
um i guess i guess the you know
potential concern
here is also that like like there has to
be some way to to link
the uh the the states as here as you're
kind of bending them
to some sort of policy selection process
presumably
um so no i'm not completely sure at
least i can't imagine
exactly how that would work it's almost
like this one is about the agent
deciding which way to walk
and then maybe there's some
proprioceptive feedback but let's
think about what this decision making
example is and then wonder about where
the motor and where these other
modalities and the continuous signal
processing also interesting
let's just walk through this discrete
time discrete opportunity space
model and then we talked about like in
active infrastream
eight with alec chance about what does
it look like to move active inference
from a discrete
into a continuous space so it's the
kinds of things that are
actively being developed and it sounds
exciting about the motor example max
yeah i mean i mean so there are you know
and you know
thomas parr has done you know a bunch of
this like we use mixed models right
where the top
the top layer is a discrete state space
markov decision process model like this
you know deciding left arm right arm but
then it feeds into a continuous
uh state space below um that actually
controls the dynamics of the movement
itself based on the decision
um my guess is it would be more uh
something more like that would be better
you know that being said these sorts of
these sorts of models are much more
about
you know behavior and choice i mean when
you're talking about neural responses
i would think that would come more be
more useful in these models to
to use them to predict the neural
responses that you would get
when a person does x versus y and see if
that matches with
the firing rates that you see
there's a paper on the mix model thing
there's a paper i think it's called like
discrete movements
to decisions and back again or something
along those lines it's in your
computation
um yeah i think it deals with all the
formal issues that kind of arise with
this
yeah thanks about it okay so
just for the sake of time here um
so so again what i did here and this is
for the agent observing
their own behavior all i did was i made
it like this
right so this is just saying when the
agent chose
uh uh state one
then it observes the observation
associated with state one
right row one with a hundred percent
probability
when it was in the hint state then it
observes that it was in the hidden state
row two with a hundred percent
probability and so forth so it's just
providing
maximally precise evidence so that it
knows what it did
um so now notice that this was
big a right so that's the generative
process
if i wanted to if we wanted to do reward
learning right if we wanted it to learn
p when the what the reward probabilities
are
then we'd have to set little a here um
and you might start out just sort of
making big a
making a little a equivalent to big a
um to start with and
and uh multiplying each of the values
in little a by a big number like 200
and what that does is it just makes it
so
the agent is really really really
confident about
um its beliefs um um
in a in that are associated with big a
um and what that does is it just
prevents learning
for anything you don't want it to learn
so if you multiply this thing by really
big number then it won't learn anything
even though technically it's learning
because it's just already too confident
um but then what you could do is for
anything that you do want it to learn
you can just redefine those with really
small numbers
right so you can say a3 here so the
probability of choosing
uh of winning choose if you choose the
left machine
you know is 0.5 so just 0.5 is all
around
right or 0.25 or whatever so this is
just saying that the agent would start
with uh completely imprecise beliefs
about whether it would win or lose
depending on what it chose depending on
context
so it would so this is what you would do
you'd kind of turn on little a
if you wanted it to learn the reward
probabilities but we're not doing that
here
so we're just showing this as examples
and same thing if you wanted to you
could do the same thing but for
outcome modality one um to have it learn
like the accuracy of the hint
um so again these are just kind of
commented on examples if you wanted to
do that kind of thing
um so now we've defined the the
likelihood matrix right the a matrix
like what states generate what outcomes
with what probabilities now we're moving
on into b
which are the transition probabilities
um
and remember that there's one of these
per state factor per action um
so and this is what i showed before that
for b1
so for state factor one the context
there's only one action quote unquote
and it's just an identity matrix this
just says the left better context
never changes within a trial um
and again i showed this before for the
second state factor
the transitions there's four different
possible transitions
transitioning from state one to any of
the other states so just to be clear
here
these transition matrices the columns
are the states you're in now
and the rows of the states that you
would move to so this is saying from any
state
you could move to state one um you know
from any state you could move to state
two et cetera
um so you end up having you know
one two three four different
actions for that state factor four
different possible transitions
so now the next thing that we do is um
we move to the preference distribution
so that's c right so this is what the
agent
wants or what the agent finds rewarding
and how rewarding the agent finds it
so to do that initially we just with no
we just say
what are the different number of
outcomes for each outcome modality
and that just looks at the size of the
row dimensions
in a so
if i do that and again this is just
using this you know
size function which is just you know
again to make it
more uh convenient or generalizable so
if i do that
then no is going to look like that
that's just saying i have three i have
three different outcome
modalities one is no hair
null no hint and hint one is
null lose and win and one is
the agent observing its own behavior
right observing action one two three or
four
um many people have asked
in the past weeks about dimensionality
of
not to go into the markov blanket
discussion but the dimensionality of
observations
and how we talk about different kinds of
outcomes
different kinds of senses for example
and it's almost looking like
it's just about the way it's specified
so
the hint could be in your ear and the
observation could be visual
or something and so you could get
philosophical and ask whether there's
really
one or two different sensory modalities
but in the context of this
inferential model that we're writing
it's almost like those things don't
really matter they're just
variables that are observed yeah i mean
so again we call these modality outcome
modalities so in this case there's three
right so like you said the hint this
could be the auditory modality and
there's three things that could hear
this could be the visual modality and
it's the three
whether it wins or loses or hasn't seen
that yet right this could be visual
and this fourth thing the third one
could be proprioception right it could
be observing or feeling what it did
i mean in this case it's probably also
somewhat visual right it observes what
it does but
um you get the point yeah so yeah so
there's just a
nice factorized you know dimensionality
for each
modality yeah um
but okay so now i've
what i've done is i've started out by
just putting zeros
in the c matrix the preference
distribution
for each outcome modality so this is
just saying for outcome modality one so
the hint
the agent has no preferences and i
should say the
the rows or the observations um for the
you know
null hint no hint i mean the columns are
time
so this is saying at time one the agent
doesn't care
whether it gets the hint or not in terms
of rewardingness
um same thing at time two same thing at
time three and i've just done that for
all three how come modalities to start
with
the only thing that we want to add
preferences for
is the win lose observations
um so in this case so that's c
for outcome modality 2 which is the win
loss thing here
so what i've done again for
generalizability is i've set this
parameter
la that is called loss of version and
i've set this parameter rs
which is that reward seeking thing which
i just defined above as rs1
and again that's just convenience so i
don't have to go down here to reset it
every time
so i define these just for again just
for convenience
and then what i say here is
so the observations again are no lose
when so this is at time
zero the agent doesn't care whether it
observes a null a loss or a win and
that's just because
it can't observe anything but a null
at time two it just prefers losing
with a value of again negative one here
for both time two and time three
but here's a little bit of a trick is
that i define
the preference for winning
as rs at time two and remember that rs
is four right now because that's what we
set it above then at time
three i set the preference as rs divided
by two
um so what that ultimately means
is that um
the this state factor will look like
this
or i mean sorry this this preference
distribution will look like this saying
it dislikes losing equally at each time
but it
wants but it gets more reward for
winning at time two than at time three
um and so that's our that's our
preference distribution
um and uh this is just all
that's basically it this is all in how
the details of how
the sketched out scenario okay four
dollars but then you got to wait 20
minutes and
however your scenario is this is about
the detail
in matrix form of how the payoffs work
and so it could be minus one or you
might ask if another number is
appropriate there
but it's kind of like that's the detail
level that's the applications and that's
where we hope to see
a lot of people exploring different
scenarios so that we can understand
better yeah and so and so you'll see
that when we actually do the like
fitting
like parameter fitting to behavior you
know one thing we'll do is we'll fit
this
right so for some people rs might be
like eight and for other people it might
be like two
um so you you find this value for each
person that best explains or
reproduces their behavior um
i mean you gave that example last week
right in the substance abuse example
where that actually has really
meaningful
or that parameter has a really
meaningful interpretation
yeah exactly um because it has to do
with
in the case of an explore exploit task
the lower rs is
basically means the more people the more
like someone is
driven to explore you know before they
kind of
jump to conclusions about which one's
the best and just keep choosing that one
it makes me makes me think about maybe
in the um
substance example or another example
it's like if we're going to have a
society that rewards good behavior and
punishes
negative behavior or something on some
issue do you go with
here's how much you get positive and
here's how much the punishment should be
should be small punishment versus large
these kinds of questions which are
really important at the individual and
the group level
not that this is even close to the
answer but it's almost like it's a way
for us to start talking about
how much do we value and how much do
individuals need different blends of
these different
attributes so really a good way to talk
about this
yeah absolutely um you know and so
like uh oh so one thing that i did want
to clarify here
is you'll notice that you know these are
supposed to be probability distributions
right
c you know each column here is supposed
to be
something that adds up to to one and
technically we work with log
probabilities
um so uh you know negative one and four
and negative one and two obviously don't
uh aren't
probabilities or log probabilities um so
in practice
um these each column here is softmaxed
and then each element is logged
which is which is how you end up with
the actual log probability distributions
that define the preferences when they're
actually used in the code
and i show that i show an example of the
numbers they turn into in the
in the or we show them in the in the
paper
um so you know last
kind of really central thing is to
define the
policies so here i'm just going to use
np here to define the number of policies
i want to allow
and here the nf thing is just the number
of actual state factors
um and that will just allow me in a
generalizable way
to say that v has
uh t minus one rows right so it's gonna
be
uh the number of actions minus
the number of times because you have to
move from time one to time two time two
to time three so there's always
one less action possibility than there
are
times in a trial um and the number of
policies again is going to be columns a
number of state factors is going to be
that third dimension
so i can start by just defining that as
ones
um and i can you know keep it that way i
just wrote this explicitly so you can
see it
and this just means again it can only
choose to stay in the same context every
time so that's not something the agent
knows or can control
whereas for state factor two i can
define each of these possible policies
stay in the start state take the hint
and then choose the left
machine you know take the hint choose
the right machine
choose the left machine and then go back
to start choose the right machine and go
back to start
and i you know i describe what each of
those means and this kind of one two
three four five thing down here
um so then if we want to and i'm not
going to do this here
um you could specify e which is the
kind of like habits you know essentially
it's just a pry over policies that
biases you
towards choosing one thing versus
another and it's just one
is in in the previous active inference
streams we talked about that as the
field of affordances
for those who are connecting it to the
ecological psychology or to the um in
activism
the prior the prior on what can be done
among
policies is the affordances of the
organism in their niche
so if you don't have the object it's not
going to be a policy under consideration
and so e is this mathematical device
that's going to be weighting policies by
their habit basically excellence is a
habit
that kind of thing
yeah i mean i i guess like i mean
technically
what you're doing is you know like the
when this makes sense functionally is is
when you're learning it
so so what you would do with little e um
and so this might start out
you know flat right with just counts of
one for the dirichlet distribution
but if you choose the same policy 20
times let's say you choose policy 3
20 times then this one this
third one here would become a 20.
and so that just means that you'd start
out with a strong bias now
for choosing policy three because you've
chosen it a bunch of times before
um and that's um an optimal thing to do
under the assumption that option three
was the one that continued to have the
lowest expected free energy every time
right so if in this model based way
based on minimizing expected free energy
you succeeded over and over again when
you chose option three
then it makes sense to build up this
kind of bias
so that you don't actually have to work
that hard cognitively to just keep doing
the thing that's right once you build up
a prior that's going to keep being right
so i guess i can see how if you
do the same sorts of things in a given
niche over and over again then you
develop priors
that bias you toward doing the things
that are successful in that niche and if
something's
if something's never been if somebody's
ever been observed then
it's unlikely it takes a different mode
of operation outside this script
if something's never been observed for
it to be considered
this is just a basic they know the pop
that's why you initiate with a non-zero
value because it's something that could
happen
yeah yeah yeah no that's true if you set
a zero anywhere in in e
then it's it's as though they don't have
that option um
yeah that's true um one other thing to
say is just like
agents can get stuck if you have
non-stationary environments
so say you have a hundred trials of one
thing
and then you switch contexts
the agent will probably be stuck
um and so i know it's just useful with
all of these parameters
they have kind of we can have our
favorite interpretations related to like
ecological psychology or whatever but
i think it's always useful to kind of
consider them functionally and use them
kind of
appropriately for this for whatever
situation it is you're modeling
yeah like that's the thing is you know
the the most useful places with this and
say like computational psychiatry are
that
if you have the right set of experiences
in these models
and you get stuck doing what's
technically base optimal given your past
experience
but that like makes you really really
maladaptive in what you're
doing uh in the new context that you're
you're in
right so you can get stuck in really
maladaptive places in parameter space
that could lead to
symptoms that look like psychiatric
symptoms for example
um so i mean this is this kind of idea
you know like
philip shortenbeck has a paper on this
as like you know uh
optimal inference and sub-optimal models
i think but uh
the whole point is you're doing the
optimal thing but your model is wrong
right um outside the optimal thing under
the assumption that your model is right
just outside of this model stream which
is really
amazing and i hope it will continue we
would also like to feature these kinds
of
direct discussions about the
computational psychiatry
so this is awesome with a walkthrough in
the code it's going to be helpful for a
lot of people who are learning that
and then let's table and find the right
time to talk about these issues because
it's really awesome
what you're describing yeah you know i
mean obviously
computational psychiatry is what i do in
practice right so yeah i'd love to
um okay so finally there's a bunch of
kind of additional parameters
right so we talked about learning rate
um which here we're just setting to 0.5
for you know arbitrarily um
beta this is the expected free energy
precision
so it controls essentially how confident
the agent is
in uh its expected free energy estimates
um so if this value is low or sorry if
this value is
high that means that the agent is really
unconfident in its expected free energy
estimates
and when that's the case then behavior
will be
a lot more random unless the agent has
strong habits
if agent has strong habits then having a
high beta value means that the habits
will have a much stronger influence
on on policy uh ultimate policy
selection
um and we actually show this is the
thing that i was talking about it's kind
of like a
random exploration sort of thing where
it's actually updated over time
so with each observation the agent
essentially updates its confidence
in its expected free energy estimates um
and then alpha is kind of like a
standard what are called inverse
temperature parameters
where it just kind of controls
randomness and action selection so once
you've chosen a policy
then that policy might say this action
is better than that action but
occasionally the
agent might still choose a different
action kind of randomly
um and uh this is actually
again this is technically like a
sub-optimal thing right you want to just
always choose the best thing
but this is actually quite important to
fit in practice because in
actual human behavior there tends to be
a notable amount of randomness and so
you need to actually fit something like
alpha
to get a model that fits behavior well
now these other two things i'll probably
skip over largely because they only have
to do with the neural process theory
primarily
but this erp thing it just controls how
much beliefs
reset at each time point um with respect
to the modeled
firing rate changes so it basically
controls how much priors at one time
point
carry over at the next time point
with respect to the neural process
theory
and then tau is um basically like an
evidence accumulation rate so it
controls how quickly
um you update your beliefs based on new
observations um
uh as attached to uh the neural process
theory um
yeah anyone digs into the code it's just
a time constant on gradient descent
yeah um
so and i go through a couple other ones
here that i explain but i'm gonna kind
of
skip over those for now so then that's
basically it
if we wanted to we could hard code what
the states what the initial states are
and what the observations are
like that by setting sno but typically
what we will do is we won't do that
we'll just let the generative process
generate the observations itself
which is probabilistic so it'll generate
with whatever the probability is of d
over d what states are actually the true
states in that context and therefore
what observations get generated
and so last thing and again i already
covered this is you just stick all these
things you defined into this
mdp right and we allow little d
which means we're going to allow it to
learn whether the left or the right
context is more likely
we set all these things you know the
learning rate and the
action precision or inverse temperature
so alpha
etc we're going to leave out
other things we could have defined like
e or like
learning a or learning b or learning c
or learning e
etc we're not going to define the states
ahead of time
and we're not going to define some of
these additional parameters that we
could include um
and then we can just kind of do some uh
nice labeling here just to so we label
what the
contexts uh mean right the semantics
we're laying on it for the figures
um and that's it
and then once we do that then we can use
this
uh little check script here just to make
sure we didn't mess anything
up in building the model and it'll kind
of nicely tell you or give you a hint
anyway about what
you might have messed up um and then
this script that i mentioned before that
we provide is the one that actually runs
the simulation
um and then finally once we have
these simulations run which will be
stored in this big mdp
then we can use these plotting scripts
to
actually show the results um
and if i set sim equals one then it's
going to do that it's just going to do a
single trial simulation which i'm going
to do
now um so i'll just let the thing run
the rest of the way
so i won't i'll get rid of these
stoppers well just to give a quick
let's give a coding recap just to where
we are at the end of the second
session while you're going through the
stop signs so
in the first session we talked a lot
about the basis of this paper
and the rationale we talked a little bit
more about who might be interested or
what kinds of experiments it was
adjacent to
and then today that was awesome with the
code because we went through a full
definition and we moved from that sort
of analytical definitions that we went
through in the first session
into seeing how they're realized in the
code and
for me at least it was really helpful to
see how a lot of these things were put
down
and then we got all the way up to line
631 or something but it could be
different in a little different version
but we got to the definition of the full
model and then the call out from that
object to another script
and then we're going to be storing all
the outputs in this kind of big
container called mdp so today we went
from
0 to 60 with the code getting all these
things
run through and defined and operated on
now we're going to look at the output
and then it sounds like in future
sessions we're going to be fitting
parameters and maybe doing a few other
things
yeah and future stuff will i mean it
sounds like maybe we're going to
wait to do to show learning next time i
guess depending on the amount of time
but
um yeah next time then we'd be in a
position to
do um actual code for learning um
we're planning on covering the neural
process theory and uh
building hierarchical models um and then
the last thing is yeah actually fitting
models to data
um so uh so yeah we'll see how much of
that we can
get through but um okay so just to
finish here
so i'm i got rid of all my little
stoppers so now i'm just gonna click
continue
and it's going to run same equals one
and what i'm going to get out of this is
a little plot like this
and also there'll be a neural neural
process there you want under here but
i'm going to ignore this for now because
we're not talking about the neural
process theory right now
um so what this top one here is
is it's hidden states so contexts um
now black equals a high probable higher
probability white equals a low
probability and so there's you know the
gray is kind of in between right so this
is saying
and these are all posteriors over states
at the end of a trial
so that's important so what this is
saying is
at the end of the trial at time three
these are the beliefs that the agent has
about what state it was in across all
these time steps
so saying at the end of the trial the
agent was completely confident
that it was in the left better context
and these little cyan blue dots here
mean that that's what the true context
was
so in other words the agent was right so
this is saying at the end of the trial
the thing was the agent was really
confident it was in the left better
context
the other state factor is choice states
down here and this is just saying that
it observed itself go from the start
state
to the hint state and then well sorry it
moved from the start state to the hidden
state to the choose left state
so those are the states the actions
correspond to that well so this is
saying it first chose the hint state
and then it shows the choose left state
or choose left action sorry these are
the actions
um this thing in the middle on the left
it's not really important
it's just kind of depicting what the
different policy options are
kind of arbitrarily based on the numbers
so i just ignored that
down here at the bottom we have the
outcomes and the outcome preference
distributions
so this is just saying it observed null
and then the left hint
and then null again this uh the third
one just says it observed
it go to the start state then to hint
state and then to choose left so just
observed its own behavior
the second one here is the win loss one
which is the most important
so you can see that this one actually
has a non-zero distribution over it
which is what means it prefers some
observations over others
and so in this case what it's saying is
it started the null state
at time two it stated in the null state
right because it took the hint
um and then it observed the win um
so in other words it got the hint it
knew what context it was
it chose left chose left
and so it observed a win so that's what
that means
um and then this distribution over
policies here is just saying at the
beginning it wasn't that confident right
so there's a lot of gray across all the
policy options
but after the hint it became really
confident at time two about what the
right policy was
um this bottom thing is um part of the
neural process theory it's simulating um
dopamine so dopamine responses quote
unquote it's the updates in the expected
precision that beta thing
um but that's how you read um these
plots um and again i won't i won't go
over the neural process theory one
because we're gonna do that next time
hopefully
um but just the last thing to show is if
you noticed
in that case the agent went to the hint
first right so it went for the hint
first i'll just do that one more time
so you can see it's very reliable that
it will
um that it will choose the hint um with
a lot of confidence
but now look what happens if i make this
rs value
higher if i make it eight which means
that the thing is uh
really really really wants to win the
four dollars basically
so in this case it should be risk taking
it should just forego the hint and just
take a guess immediately you can see
that's what it does
it has a flat distribution has no idea
whether it should choose the left one or
the right one
but it just takes a chance because it
really wants to win the four dollars and
the
value of information and the expected
free energy is low
because the reward value is really high
and so it just takes a guess
and it guesses right and it turns out
that it was in the left context so it
observes that it
lost um at time two
and because it observed that it lost in
the first o i must have been in the left
context as opposed to the right one so
at the end it still knows now that it
was in the left better context
so that's so that's what that means you
can see right away that by changing
how much the thing values reward in the
preference distribution
changes how information seeking it is
versus how risk seeking it is um
so that's uh so that's the way that that
works
um so uh do we want to
end here or do we want or is there time
to show learning
um we can absolutely go through learning
if you would like
so the topics that i've written down i
have learning which it sounds like would
be awesome to run through now
then we have actual data hierarchical
models
neural process theories and then
computational psychiatry
so that's the stack of topics let's get
to
learning today and then another time
another model stream
okay sounds good so learning
um so if you could see i sort of said
how to do this here i said for to
reproduce figure seven
so for figure nine here which is sim2
which is the initial learning
i'm gonna first set uh rs to
three um it's just a value that turns
out it's nice for showing the dynamics
of learning in a way that's
clear um so because it should start
out being information seeking and what
we want to show is how it learns to be
more uh confident and therefore starts
to forego the hint
as it builds up a stronger prior that
the left context is the
one that keeps being the case so now
what i'll do is i'll set sum equals two
but i'll show you what this does down
when i go to same equals two
um okay
so this is actually incredibly simple um
so when sem equals two is set all i do
is i say okay i want 30 trials so n
equals 30.
um to keep the mdp thing
something that um remains in that just
kind of single structure
um i redefine little mvp as big mdp and
again this is just for convenience
and then i can use this uh deal function
which is just kind of a nice convenient
function in matlab
which more or less just says repeat the
mdp
structure 30 times so now there's mdp1
mdb2 mdp3 and
all those are just the same just
identical as the initial
mdp that we built um so if i do that
then what will happen is it will look
like so okay so i'll do
so i'll do two things one is
so before um so now i just have
big mdp equals mdp so now big mdp will
look like this
right there's just a single field for t
v a b blah blah blah
right everything that we set um
now once i run this deal thing
then if i step then all of a sudden mdp
will now look like this
um where you can see now that same
structure
is repeated uh in 30 rows
and this will all start out being
identical
so what will happen now though is if i
run it
through the vbx tutorial script
then and this will take a second it will
run through
the whole thing 30 times and again this
will just take a sec
so wait let me ask something so first
maybe someone's
maybe has a little noise in their
background but it seems like this
little mdp is like a column that conveys
all the details for a single trial and
then we're making
a meta matrix we're just generalizing
the matrix into many dimensions
and now we're stacking all of the total
model as like a column
into in this case 30 trials
but you could do 100 trials in a row or
you could have 20 sets of 10 trials
so it's the idea of concatenating total
model setups
like a column so that you can do
operations on
big big potentially hierarchical sets of
models
in this keys each mdp is a row really
it's just a
giant model yeah it's just a giant
structure with gp over and over again
yeah i meant bro sorry good good call my
r centrism i'm always like thinking in
column
yeah all right but okay so now i ran it
i ran the mdp with all those different
repeated
repeated rows repeated models through
this mdp
script here and now
what you'll see is now the mdp structure
will look a little different
um
so now in addition to how the stuff in
it
had before it's also now going to have
um all this
this thing is like bin
now it's going to have all this other
stuff it's going to have
the free energy f it's going to have the
expected free energy g it's going to
have the total free energy h
it's going to have the actions u it's
gonna have the free energy
for the uh learned parameters d
um a bunch of other stuff and we have a
whole table in the in the tutorial that
says what each of these fields mean so
you can interpret them
they don't all matter enough for me to
go through them right now um
but so then once i have that then
i can generate a plot
with this little game underscore
tutorial script that i
for plotting multiple trials that we put
together
and i can run that
and it will generate a multi-trial
behavior um so so what this is showing
is the first action on each
trial um so here what you can see is
that in the
start and the colors are the probability
so dark equals higher probability and
the the blue circles are the actual
chosen actions
um so you can see for the first several
trials the agent kept taking
the hint but after a while because the
left one if the left context kept being
the one the the one that
it thought it was in at the end it
starts to be confident around trial 9
10 here that it's always just gonna be
the left one so it just immediately
chooses the uh the left arm or the left
machine um but now what you can see is
is that
it gets one wrong right because the it's
only eighty percent right that the left
one is going to be the right one
um and uh once um
could a dog be metered or is that yours
yes it is it is a dog wanting to
want to be in my lap if the dog is a
contributor then absolutely
welcome to speak yes
but uh but anyway so it starts to get
one wrong here around trial
12 right because 13 because again it's
only even when it's in the left better
context it still will lose 20
of the time right and so once it loses
it says okay actually i'm not confident
anymore so it starts
taking the hint again and that happens a
couple of times
um and so it starts kind of going uh
bouncing around um and also note that
this uh
this is under um an alpha value
right like the action precision value
that's not that high
so its behavior is a little random right
there's a little bit of randomness in it
like what a real human would do
um and so this next column this next
plot here below is just green is a win
black is a loss and the um you can see
when it loses
the uh negative free energies are larger
and again this i won't go through these
last uh
these two here just part of the neural
process theory they're like the expected
uh erps and expected dopamine responses
the model
that the theory would predict and then
this bottom one is just kind of the
evolution of the agent's priors about
whether it's going to be the left wing
or the right-wing context
um so that's how to read this
so it learns and then but
look what happens if i instead make the
thing a little bit more
uh risk seeking so i make the the value
of the the subjective value of winning
four dollars more
um and i do that just by setting
rs to four instead of three in this case
um so now
by the way it's awesome that basically
by hitting play on this script it seems
like even with minimal
tweaking people can reproduce this in
their own
setup start to play with some of the
variables
and it's just really an awesome toolkit
this is pretty cool
yeah no thank you yeah we we definitely
tried to make it as
easy as uh user-friendly as possible for
you know people who have minimal
background so i'm glad if you guys think
so
um but okay so so in this case right i
set the
uh risk seeking parameter and the
preference distribution to be a higher
number
um so now if you look the agent is now
it takes the hint twice and then just
sticks with the left every single time
even if it loses a couple of times it
just continues to be risk seeking
um and again everything else is
basically the same except the um the
predicted dopamine responses and erps
and things like that are different
um but but so that
is what it looks like when you just do
like a normal learning
um just where it says the same the
context is the same across trials and
the last thing i'll show you guys
is if i set it to three then we
engineered this kind of this reward
learning
um or this reversal learning version
right so reversal learning is for the
first several trials the left context is
better
so it's going to build up a prior that
the left context is better
but then it's going to switch to the
right context being better and we're
going to see how the agent does
now i'll show you how we do that which
is also very simple
here we're going to set n to be 32
trials
do the same kind of you know deal thing
but now what i did is i just said for
one two uh the number of trials divided
by eight
we're going to make big d one zero this
is saying the true neural process
or the true degenerative process is
going to be the left one
but then i say in the mdp for n divided
by eight plus
one day plus one to n so basically one
after this number
to the end then it's going to now be
switched to the generative process as
the right context
so in this case it just means the fir
the first eight trials
are left better and the rest of the
trials up to 32 are going to be the
right better context
so that's literally it then you just run
the same thing through the same vbx
function and you plot it with the same
plotting script so that's really very
very simple so if i do that
with risk seeking of 3 then
what we'll see happen is
um then you know
give it a second to cook here just to
give one though on that software design
instead of having five scripts called
simulation one simulation two simulation
three
it's that there's a common core and then
the simulation
scenarios are defined basically like
variables
down here in the 600s lines and then
by changing which simulation is in play
at the very top it seems like ryan is
being able to change which simulation
we're in
very uh fluidly so we can change the
simulation look at a variable change a
variable
go back up change the simulation go back
in
yeah i mean it's basically it's just
it's just an
if then function it just says if same
equals three then
do this or else if sem equals four do
this
yeah i mean it's just a very simple
if-then statement um
but uh but okay so in this case um
so i set rs equals three
um and what you can see is is in this
case
the agent just continued to take the
hint the entire time
um because it was never
it was never confident enough and the uh
you know it happened to get the first
one wrong in this case which is part of
what drove that
um but so if the if the actual
observations i got were a little
different let's actually try that again
and see
uh what um
what i would get here but this
characterizes all these interesting
things like a um
perhaps over or under eagerness to
ask for hints or acquire more
information it's showing how the model
this one is not trying to fit human
behavior we're really playing with the
bare bones
but already we're seeing that's kind of
pathological hint
behavior but it never goes when it knows
and so now something else
yeah well it's just it's parameter play
but it's going to
play out differently yeah so like in
this case where it does take the hint
every time it does
kind of start you can see on trial five
here it starts to have a little bit of
like ah maybe i should just choose the
left choose the left one immediately
but then it gets a couple wrong and then
the context changes
you can see in context learning here it
starts out oh i think the left one's
better and then it starts switching and
then around trial
11 and 12 now it starts to become more
and more confident that it's in the
right win
context so now last thing i'll
show you is what happens under that same
thing
but when i set rs equal to four so it's
a little more risk seeking
um because this actually gets
a little more fun so the risk seeking is
like a multiplication
on the money so it's like one to two
dollars versus one million to two
million like how high the stakes are
because it sounds like you're kind of
tuning up whether the agent wants the
big wins or what is it really conveying
in this model
it's just it's just essentially the
precision of the preference distribution
so it's just it's just how big the
number is
uh over win at time step
two uh but that's really all it is it's
just how high the probability is for a
win
um in the agent's model which just
encodes how strongly they prefer winning
um you could think about it as like four
dollars for them subjectively being like
the value of ten dollars or something
like that but
but all it ends up doing in practice is
it ends up saying
the uh reward value component of
expected free energy
has a higher weight than the information
value component
um is is all it ends up being in
practice
um so here you can see that the behavior
is actually you know again it's more
interesting
so you can see it takes a hint twice and
all of a sudden it's like all right i'm
confident enough i'm going to go for
choosing left immediately right it does
that for a few trials
and then the context switches you know
so it trilate it switches to being the
right context
and then it's like oh nope i'm going to
start taking the hint again and then it
observes the right one
uh a bunch of times and then it's like
okay now i'm confident it's the right
one
and then it starts choosing the right
one without taking a hit a bunch of
times now
the behavior is quite a bit more
interesting because it becomes confident
it loses confidence and then it switches
to being confident again in the other
thing
it gets one wrong around 23 it gets a
wrong one
and then it does one hint and it's like
nope i'm on the right track i just lost
one time
it's all good yep exactly
um so so that's that's the way the
learning works and if i show you you
know like i mean i'm plotting this here
but like
literally in the mvp like
it will just be if i go to the things
learning d
right so if i go to little d
trial one
um
then you know it observes you know it's
0.75.25 because it observed left the
first time
right and then at you know say like
trial eight
it's two point two
two point two uh so it didn't make
it's because that's what it's considered
it was flat still but that's because it
got something wrong that's when it was
confused
yeah and then but if i go down to say
like
you know at the end say like trial i
don't know 31 or something
then all of a sudden um it's
2 versus 13 right so it's way more
confident it's added a lot more counts
to
it being the right context that's better
um and that's you know that's really it
um
so and that's literally all the learning
is and um
you know like uh uh
chris showed you the equation for
learning um
a but you know in the um in the tutorial
paper
we also show it for um for learning
d which is even simpler it's just uh
see if i can get to it real quick here
um
learning process theory
learning uh yeah it's literally just
this
so d for the next trial is d for the
previous trial
plus eta times whatever the posterior
states were
for the previous trial um that's
you know that's literally it um
although i'm realizing uh that should be
a minus not an equals i think
but um a little typos here and there
um but anyway that's you know that's
really it
um so it's not uh it's not complicated
at all
it's just add account based on what your
posterior was over states at the end of
the last trial
um so i mean that's
you know if we're stopping at the end of
of basic learning then then that's
really it
um uh like i said four and five have to
do with estimating parameters based on
data and then
recovering parameter estimates and
fitting behavior to data and things like
that so
we'll cover that at another time awesome
well just
to um catch our breath at the end of
this really
fascinating and very appreciated stream
um
and if anyone wants to put any last
comments in the live chat they'll have
just a couple minutes to do so
let's just each take a final recap
or a final thought what do we want to
remember from this time what are we
gonna take forward into next time what
are we looking forward to
learning more about so whoever wants to
go first
maybe christopher any remarks on ryan's
presentation
and then on the code and also like your
role or which parts had you
done i was just curious about that with
all those things for the last
um so no i think i agreed with
everything that was said there
uh one thing to just say very
when when you really get your hand get a
handle on building these models
it will take i think for the most time
i've ever spent
building these models once we'd actually
figured out the model structure
was a couple of days like you you might
spend a very
very long time figuring out the model
structure but once you've figured out
the model structure everything falls in
place and it's super easy
um so it's kind of interesting in the
sense that i have some friends do like
neural network or modeling with like
spiking neural nets
and they can spend like weeks building
these models
um
the the hard work here is really
conceptual um
and then do you ask like what part of
the tutorial i wrote or versus ryan
um was that the question not a uh
partitioning just which parts were
your background drawing from or just how
how do you see similar differently i
wrote them generally speaking i wrote
the mathematical appendices and then did
like
first drafts of a lot of the techie
sections but that was kind of like my
i really really asked ryan to do that
just because i wanted to kind of get a
better understanding of
myself um and send ryan kind of
wrote a lot of the broader sections that
was kind of how that stuff worked out
um yeah i mean i mean
yeah i wrote i mean i wrote the the code
we're going through now
was was you know i took the first pass
of it um
chris wrote uh the um
the hierarchical modeling code um
which uh another another day you'll see
in a lot of the neural process
uh simulation uh code um or the
kind of custom one uh the the ones i was
showing you now are just kind of like
carl standard the ones that are in spm
but uh chris made some way way cooler
ones for the the hierarchical
neural process simulation stuff um so um
but yeah i mean a lot of this was fully
collaborative you know i wouldn't
necessarily say
you know one person did anything more
than the other um
so yeah every anyone who's like written
a scientific paper knows like
it's after the first draft has been
written it's kind of hard to tell
the finished product because when you
have heavy backwood and fold editing it
yeah i totally agree it's a great
perspective so also thanks for
sharing that so maybe now let's have our
last little
round maybe max or we'll each take a
last
step yeah i'm just uh you know to
as a lead into next week i'm excited to
hear about the neural process theory and
really
about you know looking at those dopamine
traces and it's cool to see the spiking
that you
are able to reproduce with this kind of
a model structure that does reflect
you know kind of how the exact phone
neurobiological processes might look
um one thing i'm really keen to hear
about is um the
you know the link function between your
your gradient
um on free energy and your dopamine
expression or simulated dopamine
expression levels
and the the postulated link between um
you know precision
insofar as i mean i mean these are
things that i'm just it's a little out
of my realm but um
i think it's really interesting because
fundamentally that's that's such an
elegant
uh mechanism if it's that gradient only
um from a mathematical standpoint that
it's really cool to tie that
from the math and theory into empirical
observation and using that to validate
the model
cool christopher definitely we're
excited we're excited to show you
nice do either of you want to make any
last comments
no uh this has been really fun thanks
daniel yeah yeah yeah thanks everyone
talking this whole time so yeah
people probably don't want to hear me
ramble anymore not till next time at
least but yeah
thanks everyone for watching live and in
replay and everything and just for
participating because it's the
conversations we're having the real time
errors we're
finding and the learning that we're all
contributing to so just thanks everyone
for participating and
we'll see you later for